uh joining me now to discuss the
unfolding situation from new york uh
dmitry polyansky first deputy permanent
representative of russia to the u n um
dimitri polyansky really good to talk to
you this afternoon thank you for joining
us
thank you sir
um i just want to start by um talking to
you about what um
many leaders in the west are saying that
a russian invasion of ukraine is now
seen as an
inevitability what's your view
uh well actually
only the western leaders are speaking
about this about alleged
in
inevitability of russian attack on
ukraine
uh have you heard any threats like this
from any russian politician uh i haven't
and i was browsing through the headlines
this morning and i saw for example the
ukrainian minister for defense mr
reznikov who acknowledged that there was
no russian military group capable of
launching attack at ukraine right now
the same statement was shared by the
head of national security council
so it seems that only only western
politicians are promoting this idea and
the question is why who will profit from
this uh it looks like they are
encouraging ukraine uh to commit some
kind of provocation maybe i don't know
difficult to say from my position by the
way i watched while joining you i
watched this uh
coverage from two british
soldiers or ex-soldiers on the front
line
in ukraine and i i need to reflect to
you that this is a blatant uh violation
of minsk agreements uh the point 10 of
minsk agreements adopted back in 2015
uh indicates that uh all
militant uh foreign military detachment
should be withdrawn from the territory
of ukraine under supervision of osce
including mercenaries so these guys look
like mercenaries and
i don't know why you are boasting about
it i mean not you personally but your
country because this is something that
uh
is that violates means agreements and
means agreements is the only way to
settle the crisis uh in ukraine and this
was acknowledged by security council
which adopted the resolution on this
okay in response to that there are no
russian um
military presence in ukraine right now
the uk armed forces minister james
heapey um said today we are becoming
aware of a significant number of
individuals that are assessed to be
associated with russian military
advanced force operations and currently
located in ukraine so the accusation
there being that
you know russia military presence is
where it shouldn't be in ukraine at the
moment
i think the main source for giving
judgments on the judgments of this is
the osce the special monitoring mission
and in it in its reports uh doesn't uh
doesn't indicate to russian military
presence in ukraine and there were
several uh events in the u.n where our
ukrainian colleagues tried to claim that
there are hundreds or hundreds of
thousands or
tens of thousands of russian troops
allegedly in ukrainian territory and the
representatives of osce who were present
at these meetings they couldn't confirm
this so with all due respect frankly
information from the uk
uh is not
cannot be considered by reliable
information this is the experience that
shows this so you're denying the
presence of russian military advanced
force operations in ukraine right now
well from my perspective in new york i
don't see such presence and uh i uh i
see i think that the osce is the main
source for making judgments on this okay
what you will have seen from new york is
what um a lot of us have seen now is the
satellite imagery of russian troops uh
massing on the border with ukraine uh
it's estimated over a hundred thousand
troops have moved to the border and why
are they there then if it is not to
threaten some kind of incursion or
invasion what are they doing there
first of all when you say at the border
you need to define what is at the border
because even according to the maps that
i saw in uh in western media including
british media that the troops are
stationed sometimes hundreds kilometers
from the border russia russia has long
and big borders why particularly the
border near ukraine
but uh did what what is different from
what was happening before because there
were maneuvering of russian troops on
the border with ukraine on the border
with other countries on other parts of
our territory before 100 000 that many
that's that's quite a big amount that's
what's concerning the west is this is
this is being excused as military
operations it's a very extensive
military operation happening close we
can we can argue how many miles from the
ukrainian border but it's the closest it
can get to the ukrainian border
well these are only claims first of all
and secondly i quoted to you the
ukrainian minister of defense which i do
not you do not usually do but still he
says that there is no significant
deployment at the border which with
which would uh signif which would mean
that uh russia is preparing an attack
so that's how i saw the headlines today
uh this morning in the news even
ukrainians are now doubtful about these
facts so i think only united kingdom and
united states maybe are promoting this
uh these uh allegations and this version
of the events again nothing
extraordinary is happening we are moving
troops in our border in our territory uh
we have all the rights to do so we have
done this before there can be different
explanations to this and these all
explanations it is our national matter
there can be maneuvering of the troops
there can be
the uh
i don't know exercises of the troops
that are being conducted and this is not
linked to some imminent or not imminent
military operation every country does
this i know that there are nato
maneuvering not far from our borders and
nobody is uh seems to be preoccupied by
this in the west though it's uh exactly
provocative okay so
why so much about this this information
i can't really understand it happens in
the heads of our of our western
colleagues and no nowhere else so you so
you feel that the west is making a big
deal out of this if that is the case why
why is russia entering into weeks worth
of talks with nato allies about the
what's happening on the border
but it's not about what's happening on
the border this perception is absolutely
absolutely wrong this is western
perception we are entering the talks
about
security guarantees which are not
related at all with the situation on the
board with ukraine so that's not how we
see the situation
but western leaders are looking at these
talks and it is being pegged as to
what's happening on that border and
they're looking for reassurances that
ukraine is secure and nato allies are
helping ukraine as a defensive measure
it's not about reassurance for western
countries and for ukraine it's about
reassurances for russia and we started
these negotiations it was our initiative
we proposed the draft treaties with the
united states and with nato it's not
about the situation on the border with
ukraine or whatever it's about long-term
ironclad
legal guarantees for russia which are
long overdue and uh if you look at the
texts of what we proposed
uh this is about this and the
interpretation that it's about
de-escalating of situation the border is
totally the invention of our western
colleagues talk to me about then what it
is you talk about russia wants
reassurances what reassurances does
russia want what does russia want from
these talks then because what the west
is seeing is russia uh coming
looking for looking for something and
they're seeing all the troops masked on
the border with ukraine and seeing it as
uh a non-verbal threat if you like
uh russia wants reassurances about our
security our security has suffered a lot
because of nato enlargements because of
the
promises that were were made by the west
that were not kept after that at
perestroika time and in the 90s and
it's it's it's difficult not to be
concerned when you see how nato
infrastructure how nato forces uh bring
abroad uh closer to our borders
regardless of all the promises
regardless of all the what about the
reassurances ukraine wants for its
security because it is looking across
the border at those 100 000 plus troops
gathering it's looking at russia saying
we don't want you to be a member of nato
ukraine is its own sovereign state you
can decide its own future
so what about the reinsurance
reassurances that ukraine wants from
russia
of course ukraine is a sovereign state
it can decide its future but it cannot
uh provide its security at the expense
of other nations including russia and
this is the key osce principle which is
uh which is very often overlooked in the
west
when you speak about this situation so
you shouldn't forget that we also have
the right to out to security and that
the uh extension of nato towards our
borders is a direct threat to our
security and we we need to be vigilant
about this we have been raising this
issue for many years
and uh i think that it has it has been
formulated very uh concretely right now
these days and that's why we propose
this uh this uh
draft treaties and what about you asked
about ukraine reassurances the best
reassurance from from ukraine for
ukraine for its security and for its
stability is the implementation of minsk
agreements is the only internationally
acknowledged uh acknowledged document uh
that uh that will bring peace uh to
ukraine it implies uh
uh dialogue with donetsk and lugansk
which kiev avoids so the best
contribution to ukraine's security which
the west can make is to force ukraine to
encourage ukraine uh to implement uh
minsk agreements which are also blessed
by the security council it's very simple
we're running out time but just a final
word um dimitri polyansky in terms of
talking about ukraine security the west
is saying it is on the defensive russia
saying it is on the defensive as well um
what would it take for russia to decide
to form some kind of incursion in
ukraine or invade or is that not on the
table
at all
well it's not on the table at all we
repeatedly told it
so the only the only source of this
preoccupation of this hype that is
created around this situation is uh the
are the heads of our western colleagues
who repeatedly denied it and we deny it
uh
right now as well okay dmitry polyansky
first empty permanent representative of
russia to the un i hope we speak again
uh over the next few weeks really good
to talk to you this afternoon thank you
very much for your time